and when you see prime minister people
like
um
john glenn leading government people
like kemi badanok people like
neil o'brien one of the intellectual
architects of levelling up
do not feel prime minister the
variability capacity of this government
to address these enormous overhanging
issues
is is is deteriorating as we speak well
i think
when i when i came into
uh into into parliament i think they're
about 140 conservative mps i don't
remember exactly what the number uh was
uh there are now
uh
365 or so
360 uh there are there abouts there is a
wealth of talent stephen
and uh
we should we should be we should be
confident in our ability to and as your
point about um the the government
focusing the government is certainly
focusing on the issues that matter and
today we're cutting taxes for everybody
uh by 330 pounds uh for
30 million people uh just this day i've
talked about the 1200 pounds uh we've
just got half
you're being very kind about um as on
the back benches but actually i think
you're going to find it extremely hard
to appoint people of the same caliper of
the kind of ministers i've mentioned to
you i think we find it extremely
difficult
you know you don't need to reply to that
point i think the point has been made uh
you're catching my are you a little bit
under time yes yeah thank you
i mean
just following on from that you've had
more resignation since any prime
minister's in 1932
michael grove has told you to go the
shed adds up the game's up really will
you be prime minister tomorrow
of course uh mr mcneil uh but next week
but i'm here to
rather than giving any running
commentary on my own
i'm just turning your laptop
and talk about what the government is
doing and okay and that is
so that's what i was telling stephen
and
wedding along